what about the randori just out of
curiosity again i i haven't ever had the
opportunity to train with folks at a
high level
um is you know in jiu jitsu
the there's different gyms at different
styles but i've noticed that at the
highest levels people
can go pretty hard in a certain kind of
way where it's it's more technical and
you're not you're moving at a hundred
percent
but
the power is not at a hundred percent
it's it's a weird little dance it's it's
techn like you're not really
um
forcing stuff you're more focused on on
the right timing the right
uh positioning of hands and feet and
body and all those kinds of things
you're not like forcing stuff in the way
you would in competition like really the
power does that sound similar to you for
the way you tried to do randori so
there's different styles of judo and i'd
say the japanese style the technical
style of judo is exactly what you just
talked about it's like it's almost like
two guys in pajamas right we're not
going we're not using we're using
minimal effort
maximum efficiency we're moving around
and we're trying to feel that movement
and it's timing and finesse and
technique and fun and clean throws and
when you you know when you train in
japan
you can train 15 rounds of randori five
minute rounds that's 75 minutes of of
straight you know sparring you can do
that straight in japan without a problem
i mean you'll get tired of course you're
going to fall a lot you're going to
throw a lot
but it's very like free feeling
and it's technical as you explained but
then when you go to europe and you try
to do rounds with the europeans they are
very physical they don't have that same
finesse in their training that they do
in japan and in europe you'd be
hard-pressed to do eight rounds of
randori in a night it's so physically
exhausting because so much effort is
going into just fighting and fending off
the gripping system and the power of
your opponent you're physically drained
after eight rounds of randori so it's a
much different feel uh when you say
europe do you mean germany france
britain russia is there a lot so
there's a kind of
similarity to all of those kinds of
approaches the only difference would be
russia that they do a lot more active
drilling a lot more sequential movement
training they don't focus as much on
randori you'll do much fewer rounds in
russia
during training camps than you would in
in those other countries we just talked
about france germany et cetera what
about in this kind of american system
where you have much less talent
uh to work with is
did you uh
just select whatever works for the
particular athletes or do you have a
something you prefer in your system
so you need a combination of all of it
if you're going to win at the olympic
level you have to be able to deal with
the finesse of the japanese the
physicality of the europeans you have to
focus on on the ground nawaza aspect
because a lot of people are weak there
in the world of the sport of judo that's
a chance to win
we've sort of developed our american
system of judo at least for the last i
say probably the last 20 years it'd be
the american system of judo which relies
heavily on taking the individual and
whatever techniques they they do
perfecting those techniques and
the combinations and other throws that
go with those throws but then
implementing and overlaying an american
system of gripping nawaza conditioning
mentality training methodology
like in in game planning you know to
beat your opponents and i think that's
the that's the secret sauce to success
for the fair americans because there's
no way
if we don't have eight partners to train
within the night that are going to give
us good rounds right we might have two
you know so we have the same guy four
times those two people four you know two
times each now i have four good rounds
the rest of the rounds i'm not being
pushed to the limit so we train
differently
um and a lot of times we do a lot of
stuff like shark bait when our athletes
are preparing for competition for
example when kayla or travis were
preparing for competition
we might only have 20 people in the
whole gym work to work out with those
two
olympic medalists right and of those 20
people maybe four of them are travis's
size you know maybe there's only one
girl in the room for kayla she's got to
train with guys and then the other ones
are teenagers that are too weak to train
with either one of them so what we would
do is just put together four or five
people that could you know give them a
challenge
and we'd line them up and they would do
a minute a minute a minute a minute and
then do five minutes in a row as hard as
they can
that person can go hard for a minute
with travis or kayla they can't go five
minutes hard but they can go one minute
hard so it made their training much
much more intense much more physically
demanding and then rinse and repeat that
six times or eight times in a night
you know they just got 40 minutes of
intense randori the person that was
training with them that wasn't as good
only had to do six or eight minutes of
training the whole night yeah you know
so
it's so
it's so difficult
because you then you look at like
the russian national team
and you have just world champions and
so
um
you even have like um what is the tom
brands and terry brands and the in the
wrestling system you have like
these people it's a small group of
people but they're all some of the best
people in the world and they're going
head to head and yeah you don't
necessarily get a good look kind of a
variety of styles but just the qualities
there and even that is missing for
people your size in america because
and that is so difficult to work with we
should make scales and makes travis's
story that much more amazing
you